un choc pour cette journée de r2 où ils
premier recevait son dauphin l'équipe 2
de bobigny un match alléchant sur le
papier qui ne tient pas toutes ses
promesses sur le terrain lors de la
première période les deux équipes se
neutralisent 0 à 0 à la pause en
première mi temps on n'était pas
craintif mais on était prudent donc on
n'a pas pu vraiment jouer notre notre
football on n'a pas pu aussi mettre en
place de ce que le coach a demandé donc
du coup c'était une mi temps mitigé en
santé qu'on n'était pas vraiment en
danger mais n'en voulait pas à s'exposer
en seconde période où ils insistent mais
ne parvient pas à marquer un manque de
réussite qui se paye cash des jours de
bobigny marque sur cette action 1 0 les
yvelinois poussent pour revenir dans la
partie mais ils n'arriveront pas à
égaliser 1 0 ce sera le score final sur
leur seule occasion du match bien il
trouve le but est la moins été efficace
on a manqué d'envié on avait à coeur de
gagner ou mot de passe de perdre sur
leur seule occasion 10 ème mi-temps et
ils ont réussi à nous faire mal je pense
qu'ils ont réussi à nous faire déjouer
on n'a pas pris le match par le bon bout
donc il ya beaucoup de frustration et de
déception dans le vestiaire des joueurs
et du coach oscillations après cette
défaite oui toujours leader mais ne
compte plus que deux points d'avancé à
sept matches de la fin du championnat ça
relance tout le monde donc notamment
embaument unique sans d'arnaud donc ils
vont rien lâcher c'est à dire que faudra
quand même être vigilant par rapport à
eux mais encore une fois comme j'ai dis
qu'est-ce qu'on a le destin en main un
autre justement
mettre toutes les chances de notre côté
pour justement arrivé à la fin de
l'année et a toujours primé pour
continuer à croire en la montée ou se
déplacera ce dimanche 3 avril sur le
train de vallière crown quatrième du
classement